we're launching a new medical series
this morning is called Grand Rounds
that's a practice of senior medical
professionals who teach other doctors
about advancements in health care and
treatment our focus today is breast
cancers who may know October is National
Breast Cancer Awareness Month
one in eight women will get the disease
in her lifetime but with medical
advances the number of deaths has
plunged nearly 40 percent from 1989 to
2015 our dr. David agus is leading
leading cancer expert has presented
Grand Rounds for more than two decades
around the world
he leads the University of Southern
California's Westside cancer center
joins us at the table good to see you
always took two decades makes me sound
old no it just makes you sound like an
expert yeah but it's great to hear that
there's a drop in the rates why it's
pretty amazing right I mean all of a
sudden it's dropping we're screening
people are getting mammograms like they
should and we're also getting better at
treating it's or early breast cancer
when you take it out and then give
certain treatment you can dramatically
reduce the rates of recurrence and
that's equaling more people surviving
this horrible disease we're not new
treatments what are some of the most
exciting new treatments they're out
there it's a wild time for doing what we
do is that now when it's person is
diagnosed we can look at the genes and
basically see the on and the off
switches and we can target them so we
call that molecularly targeted therapy
and it's out there and it's working and
saving lives and then the newest form is
called immunotherapy which is blocking
that don't eat me signal that's on the
cancer and allowing the patient's own
immune cells to attack the cancer both
of those are making people live longer
better
what percentage of breast cancers are
hereditary about five to ten percent are
hereditary we know two genes are almost
deterministic so brca1 and brca2 means
that you have you know up to a sixty to
eighty percent chance of getting breast
cancer in your lifetime the test because
the gene was patented several years ago
was thousands of dollars now the Supreme
Court said you can no longer patent a
gene in our country and that test is $99
so do you think more people should get
the test to me it's a no-brainer right I
mean you don't get false positives with
this test but knowledge is power and
knowing what to do and you know when
Angelina Jolie very you know you know
heroically said I have the
faulty gene it really opened the doors
to say it's okay to actually look and to
talk about it
you know besides skin cancer it's one of
the most diagnosed cancers why is that
you know it's a great question right you
have a lot of muscle in your body and
yet your breasts are a small fraction of
that and yet one in eight women get
breast cancer and so we don't know is
the true answer but the lobules that
make milk they can get cancer and we
start to see a go increase decade by
decade so in the 20s it's rare going up
to the 70 days what gets much more
common but this is a disease where we
know early detection matters mammograms
not the greatest tests in the world if
you're the consumer not fun oh it's not
listen I had one the other day I swear
to you David if men had to go through it
we have to go to if you had your
you-know-what smash they figure out
another way to do it because depending
on the tech you get it's very
uncomfortable or it's also very pleasant
do you see a day where you don't have to
have that procedure done that way well
you know Marie Curie invented the x-ray
a hundred years ago we're still using it
now to diagnose breast cancer it's a
great test and everyone should have it
but you're right we need more research
and better ways to detect this disease
what is better what is the big
unanswered question about breast cancer
you know I think the biggest unanswered
question is why does it happen yeah and
you know we have ways to prevent it if a
woman takes some of these estrogen
modulating drugs like relax afina
tamoxifen you could dramatically reduce
the incidence of it and we know taking
hormone replacement therapy can actually
raise the incidence we know alcohol is a
risk factor we know being sedentary is a
risk factor being overweight is a risk
factor so we're knowing about those but
we still don't know the route of why it
happens David agus thank you thank you
guys great to have you here as always
thank you so much reminder I need to get
a mammogram October you know thank you